handcuffed and dressed in a prison
jumpsuit Hadi matar stood silently his
head bowed his lawyer entered a not
guilty plea on his behalf
he's charged with the attempted murder
of Sir Salman Rushton
[Applause]
the suspect was tackled to the ground at
the front of the stage the injured
author receiving first aid a few feet
behind
members of the audience willing him to
survive brother
the 24 year old accused who appear in
court again next week was born in
California but recently moved to
Fairview New Jersey I would never even
consider someone like like that living
in this neighborhood
you know it's unbelievable I thought
that maybe somebody got shot
I'm hearing all these helicopters I
didn't know what happened I lived right
around the corner terrible terrible the
author who's 75 was airlifted from the
scene to a hospital in Pennsylvania he
had sustained approximately 12 star
wounds puncturing his eye and liver and
causing Serious injury to his neck chest
and abdomen
while sir Salman Rushdie receives
medical attention here the investigation
is spanning several States as law
enforcement agencies combine their
efforts to establish the motive for this
attack and if there are grounds for
further charges
Salman Rushdie has lived under threat
since the publication of his novel The
Satanic Verses in 1988. some Muslims
deemed his depiction of the Prophet
Muhammad Blasphemous Iran's leader
Ayatollah Khomeini imposed a death
sentence on the streets of Tehran
they've been responding to the attack
I heard the news on the TV and I was so
glad because of the insult salmon
Rushdie had made against our prophet and
the fat were issued against him finally
worked
they should know that sooner or later
the rights will always overcome God
willing he pays for what he did
world leaders have condemned the
stabbing Salman Rushdie has spent his
life defending free speech he's now
engaged in a very different battle David
Blevins Sky News in Erie Pennsylvania